[Musique]
mais un de faire du latin
et vu relève est le plus beau le
s'il est fleuri au sol
zago bolelli
[Musique]
peut-être chocolat souvent
je vois ni de gaza car l'info de tuer
[Musique]
signez ici comment
un sac
[Musique]
et un libre demi million nature bonne
chance dehors
dans mr
et
[Musique]
mais
on
[Musique]
faut que je te dise quelque chose
mais
rien n'a changé c'est comme tu l'as
laissé merci alors je t'ai mis des draps
propres de nouveaux oreillers
ils sont en plumes ouais ils disent que
l'on dort mieux ou un truc du genre
elle est très différente de la personne
qu'il était quand vous étiez au lycée tu
verras robin je suis amoureux d'elle tu
es ma soeur tu pourrais faire un effort
ok donc appelle moi si tu as besoin de
quelque chose d'accord
bonne nuit bonne nuit
je
et
salut les filles salies vous allez au
bar tous les justiciers dire bonjour
bonjour fallu robin bhar salut ça va
bien et vient boire un verre avec nous
[Musique]
allez viens j'aimerais bien vraiment
mais elle vient juste de rentrer je
comprends et je peux te parler une
seconde m je vous l'empreinte une minute
[Musique]
ça devient intéressant
pourquoi rosemary et tu attends tu
parles de ces conneries du lycée
rose-marie flirter avec son père chante
tous les jours tout le monde flirte avec
son père c'était le seul prof sexy de
l'école non je vais pas vous y fier et
moi je suis sûr que toute la ville c'est
que tu les aimes bien pourtant c'est
tellement vrai
on devrait pas parler de ça ici ça
craquait
devine quoi je lui ai dit pour nos 2
et je sais je sais j'aurais dû le faire
depuis longtemps c'est juste que je
voulais attendre le bon moment mais
s'était jamais le bon moment enfin bref
on s'en fiche elle s'est maintenant et
ça va aller tu vas au festival ce week
end
oui ouais ça va me changer les idées
ah oui oui est ce qui me plaisait c'est
que tu devais venir avec moi je suis
désolé c'est pas facile
ouais les choses vont pas être faciles
pour moi non plus tu vois ce que je veux
dire
[Musique]
salut salut tu fais du café way vient je
prépare le petit déj
d'accord j'arrive
ce sect les aime croustillantes c'est
assez croustillant pour toi c'est
délicieux sa meilleure que la bouffe en
prison alors c'est quoi le burn the moon
quoi et comment
comment t'es au courant de ça c'est sûr
ton calendrier c'est vrai ouais et basse
et c'est ce que je devais faire ce week
end mais je vais annuler je vais pas te
laisser tout vas-y j'ai plein de trucs à
faire de toute façon
ok j'ai rien à faire mais c'est quoi
exactement
ben c'est un festival de musique
spirituelle au milieu du désert avec un
tas de hippies c'est débile je sais mais
rose marie voulait y aller tu as l'air
plutôt cool sérieux avant tu aurait
détesté
je veux y aller sérieux ouais ouais
c'est carrément flippant de rester ici
toute façon d'accord pourquoi pas
allons-y et tuture veut du jus d'orange
je veux bien on va au berne de moon
[Musique]
jokinen
mot de lui
maurice de e-commerce mai
c'est que heu
jolie voix
c'est
l'agefi qu'à vous et je sers me disent
oh qu'il est beau
j'aurais dû être capable maintenant
je vous
ça non
d'avis que tous les adultes de toi est
magnifique c'est pas une surprise
la photo d'art
anthony floch esprit chic
mais tu me
c'est encore loin parce que j'ai plus de
réseau la plus personne n'a de réseau ok
on reste sur la route 14 pendant encore
23 km et après on prend la route de la
vallée de la mort c'était quoi ce bruit
je sais pas trop ok cette fois c'était
quoi
d'accord ok je vais m'arrêter je vais
regarder ça
c'est pas vrai creux
j'en sais rien allez ouvre toi
les verts
est sûre que tu avais remis depuis
shanghai ont maintenu qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant
il faut un dépanneur appelle un
dépanneur et on capte pas ici comment tu
veux que j'appelle un dépanneur regarde
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un problème avec la voiture
bonjour oui exactement dr c'est le pire
endroit pour tomber enfin il ya plein de
trucs qui pourrait vous bouffer leur
ouais je sais que demain ça fait un peu
plus rien pour lui fais pas ta garde
jasmin les voitures récente il faut un
ordinateur pour savoir ce qu'ils ont
mais si je vous remarqué au sérieux ça
serait vraiment sympa franchement merci
merci vous y étiez presque oui presque
vous allez où le jeune homme va un
festival de musique burn the moon
ouais j'en ai entendu parler le soleil
se couche
ouais vaut mieux pas traverser la vallée
de la mort en pleine nuit soyez prix
d'un amusez vous bien
waouh
qu'est ce qu'il à votre bébé il faut
sans avait amené quatre autres ouais
écoutez je sais pas elle a fait une
espèce de bruit de cliquetis incessament
et après elle s'est mise à fumer d'un
coup alors en acheter un neuf ok vous
allez un concert ou un truc du genre
vous aimez ce rock un peu déjanté en
quelque sorte vous pensez qu'elle a
chauffé
ben c'est possible je suis là pour vous
le dire elle est chaude ce soir fait pas
attention à lui mais c'est un bon mécano
chercheurs qui va s'occuper de vous
maintenant et mec
encore merci c'était sympa de vous
arrêter ce temps prugent temps près d'un
café un geste qu'est ce que t'en pense
faire un tout petit geste est bien
oui
oh oui c'est très généreux de vote car
il ya un bar restaurant de ce côté vous
pouvez vous poser pendant que qui
s'occupe de la panne et c'est une bonne
idée merci merci encore merci pour tout
bonne chance à vous
tu peux aller au bar avec elle juste
pour s'assurer que tout va bien
alors qu'est ce que ça dit désolé de te
dire ça mon pote et ça va te coûter dans
les 600 dollars non sérieux 600 dollars
donc vous pouvez laver paris dont la
déconne j'ai cru bon c'était au milieu
nulle part quand tu vois des gens fumer
dans un bar
[Musique]
j'ai pas j'ai besoin d'un verre excusez
moi bonjour je peux avoir une vodka soda
s'il vous plaît c'est la pierre première
ride ou rome d'accord on n'a qu'à
prendre des biens light trois bières
light s'il vous plaît et sérieuse
bienvenue au bar de la dernière chance
une fille qu'est-ce que je vous sers du
houleux et sombre où les chambres tout
ce que j'aime
faut que je me mette de l'eau dans les
yeux ou un truc dans le genre homo le le
sombre j'adore ce qu'ils aient ou non
c'est ce que je préfère le o2 et sens où
le et sombre c'est plutôt ironique comme
commandes
pourquoi ça tu sais quand on est dans le
désert et tout ça la pluie il y en a
jamais
oui
les filles je crois que vous êtes
beaucoup trop jolie pour être dans un
trou à rats peau mais comme celui-ci je
suis désolé est ce que mon ami vous
dérange je te plaît ne faut pas les 90
et un peu bourré mon pote
alors je suis bien d'accord alors on
arrive de reno on va dans le désert pour
assister à un festival
je m'appelle troy au même endroit bah
oui oui en tout cas on essaie notre
voiture est en panne
dommage voici maintien avec moi alors
alors bon
donc le le mécano a dit qu'on avait
explosé le joint de culasse est allée
lui prendre deux jours tel jour
ouais donc je pensais appeler quelqu'un
pour venir vous chercher et vous ramenez
moi je vais rester ici avec rosemary on
va prendre
robin une chambre d'hôtel tant que la
voiture soit prête excusez moi les gars
on a un camping car et on a plein de
lait alors si ça vous dire avec c'est
très sympa merci mais je crois pas que
ce soit une bonne idée mais pourquoi pas
c'est mieux d'attendre dix cygnes le
festival dure deux jours votre voiture
sera réparé dans deux jours on veut
ramènera ici après le festival
enfin si ça vous tente c'est juste entre
copains on n'a pas vraiment d'autre
option
[Musique]
y a pas de vie comme ça arrive non
qu'est ce que tu fais quoi il est sexy
durée qu'il a 12 ans il y en a 24 je lui
ai demandé et il est fiancé mais je vais
le faire craquer tu as vraiment un grand
et alors les fera nuit dans une heure
ouais t'inquiète pas il y en a pas pour
l'an 40 minutes et c'est quasiment que
de la ligne droite
vous en faites pas des gars
[Musique]
alors pourquoi ce festival franchement
j'en sais rien j'espère juste que ce
sera bien eh ben on est exactement dans
le même car j'ai entendu plein de bonnes
choses
c'est vraiment trop beau pour être
dangereux dans le corps je sais mais
j'ai grandi à tehachapi et je peux te
dire qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
meurent dans la vallée de la mort et ce
presque tous les ans non c'est vrai je
me souviens de l'histoire de ce couple
mariés sont sortis
vous savez pour voir le restera qu ils
ont emmené leur petite fille
et comme vous le savez au restera qu
sais c'est que des petits trous tank
bien sûr c'est pas la peine de vous dire
qu'il ya pas dans les eaux ensuite il me
semble qu'ils se sont trompés de route
sûrement croisement de tilly kettle
il n'avait pas emmené assez d'eau je
crois qu'ils ont tenue genre trois jours
ses origines dans un site si si je me
souviens bien
les parents sont allés chercher de
l'aide et lpb est mort sur la banquette
arrière écoute on voit au milieu de
nulle part j'ai pas besoin d'entendre
tes histoires de paix des morts
et ça vous dit de faire un jeu go fiche
je sais pas y jouer quoi pas un jeu à
voir wade accord lessiveuse l'heure
c'est toi le dilemme et on joue à feu
claude jacquot dealers qui appelle à
tous
voilà pour toi et regarde donc je dois
deviner ta carte du premier coup sinon
je dois voir le nombre de gorges et
correspondant à ce pas l'intention de
parler tu me dis plus ou moins
c'était une guerre mondiale
je ne savais pas
tellement
tellement stupide je sais vibrer en
effet
hier j et après tu vois
aussi c'est moi
tu as beaucoup manqué à robin
si jamais tu veux dix noms serra
vous les gars ça
h merci
abo
ouais
bientôt assesseurs par d
août a eu tous ces trucs écoutez les
gars vous donnerai bien son ombre il est
un peu paranoïaque et j'avoue qu'il a
super bien effritée ces deux c'est pour
ça que je t'aime bien tu vois parce que
je ramène toujours des tractions savez
quoi les gars j'ai franchement
l'impression de conduire un squat de
jeunes qui seront savate étoiles
c'est un petit goût de rigole pas les
petits jeunes et le gave et même des
clients servis vient dire minutes de
bien que je le dis on dirait qu'on va
passer un butin pour moi barghouti de
gaz oui c'est à quelqu'un c'est la bonne
bon eh bien si vous continuez à fumer
ici je vais devoir faire un [ __ ] de
trop aux ciseaux dans la fumée pour voir
la route
ça ressemble plus trop aidé route là on
dirait que ça va se paie un peu dans le
coin
toi je trinque à notre merveilleux week
end
la vache sur les coins s'est renversé
tout note mme assez bon [ __ ] de route
pour yves je vais voir dehors si c'est
le cas ils ont s'en occuper et j'ai un
as c'est bien ou pas ça craint on dirait
ya pas de doute sherlock génial c'est
quoi ce bordel [ __ ] oh c'est super
profond ça va tu sais quoi va pas te
promener et laisse nous gérer ça sent
même pas une route on voit pas vraiment
si c'est une route ou pas ok donc on
doit être juste là tu vois ce truc et on
veut rejoindre furent inscrits qui s'est
à peu près 12 km dans cette direction là
donc ça va le faire
il ya tellement des toiles la vache en
fait t'es une [ __ ] de lippi tout
pourquoi est-ce qu'on suit cette route
qu'est ce que tu veux dire c'est une
route réservée aux véhicules
tout-terrain bon puisqu'on est coincé
pourquoi on compterait pas ici cette
nuit
ouais tu as sûrement raison parce que je
crois pas qu'on puisse rouler jusqu'à
demain matin
ça peut être dangereux donc et du pays
si tu répètes peyote encore une fois
très dur je te tue tentant et qu'est ce
qu'il est devenu ton pote aubin il
essaye de se trouver depuis que sa femme
l'a quitté
on est vraiment au milieu de nulle part
ouais je sais c'est magnifique et a vu
ses étoiles
oui je crois que la soupe est prête
qui en veut nam ça fait quel effet le
peyotl bas je crois que c'est
probablement le plus beau trip que tu
auras jamais tu vas le voir et tu planes
rageant toute la nuit
tu va marcher sur ses pas sur des ponts
fait de galaxies tout ce que tu va
ressentir ça va ressembler à désolé de
dire ça mais ce sera comme un orgasme
dis toi que la dernière fois que jamais
pris le chat bcd de mon ex copine
andré est venu me rendre visite c'était
comme une explosion de couleurs
vous savez comme comme un arc en ciel ou
un truc comme ça et je pouvais voir son
âme à l'intérieur de ma tête j'ai pas
miauler n'ont rien à dire ça parce que
je voulais tiers bien sûr je dis juste
que ça a été une expérience spirituelle
vrai rêve la première et dernière fois
que tu la fais tu veux dire c'était il
ya trois jours au boulot et abrutis
s'établir à ses fins d'abord c'était de
l'a6b et j'ai démissionné
il a démissionné à l'amiable on s'étire
voix il était très à l'amiable je crois
tu avais le pouvoir j'espère qu'il m'a
fait une recommandation on s'en fout
vous en voulez ou pas je vais essayer ok
ok j'ai dire quoi j'ai dit que je
voulais goûter deux ans en prison et ça
y est c'est une racaille
ok ce grain flippant
et tu as dit quoi
je
tu viens de dire quelque chose rodilhan
ces bons laisse couler j'édicté tegra
flippante jasmin se faire à tour dj
c'est quoi attends j'ai avec toi jay jay
va pas trop loin hockey bravo c'était
super bien je suis désolé
france le bois ce pilote non tu veux
goûter sur wii comme tu veux un peu que
c'est dégueulasse mais vous allez adorer
ça je vous assure guy bois tu es sûr
allez vas-y
tu sens quelque chose pas encore
hu
quoi
car les étoiles
ouais il y en a plein
[Musique]
quand est-ce que ça m'a fait rêver
y'a des trucs de fou dans ce monde quand
on y réfléchit c'est un [ __ ] laveur
changer de couleur s'il 2 0 ça sera un
de ces pandas roux qu'on voit dans les
eaux j'aimerais bien avoir un panda
route compagnie
je nourris red chips donc les étoiles
sont censés être un genre de boules de
lumière qui meurt c'est ça et si c'était
comme ça en vrai en fait le ciel c'est
comme un gros dôme noir et les étoiles
sont comme des petites roues d'aiguilhe
et puis ce serait un genre de lumière
divine qui passerait à travers ce serait
plutôt cool je pense pas que j'aurai
envie d'aller dans un trou noir
ça doit faire mal mais j'irais bien dans
un trou très rencontres comme ça je
pourrais aller de l'autre côté de
l'univers
tu sais qui tu es
le petit gars d'amérique du sud les
premiers qui a découvert des juges
c'était une bonne idée m
sur lui
dans les cales
[Musique]
et les gars vous connaissez van gogh 10
à moi je comme si on gagne on travaille
ensemble il est vilain pour parer à moi
il est quoi je suis plus beau il
n'arrive pas à voir le vent le soleil va
bientôt se lever
c'était cool cette soirée je crains les
étoiles
et oui moi oui voies à l'aide de marchés
autant de ma tête oui toi arrête de
marché autour de ma tête mon pote
compris merde vidange on était quoi tu
parles je veux avoir des enfants avec
toi
robin c'est vrai c'est vrai tu es la
plus la plus belle chose est la plus
pure que j'ai jamais vu
tu est parfaite
on
je suis pas parfaite
c'est tu l'aies je veux me marier avec
toi et aussi je veux avoir des petits
bébés avec toi comme jeff tu sais elle
était si petite si mignonne c'était
avant que ma mère tombe malade
oui
ne m'a toujours pas dit ce qui s'était
vraiment passé là bas elle s'est pas
ouverte à moi et c'est ma soeur
j'ai l'impression d'avoir échoué
ce qu'on voit bien qu'elle est apprécié
t'es pas d'accord
peut-être oui
j'ai vraiment l'impression de te
connaître
oui je te connais
tu es vraiment très belle
je peux tu embrasses i
je travaille
[Musique]
et
on
[Musique]
bonjour qu'est ce que c'est
omer
good morning vietnam
[Musique]
réveil groovy et toi l'isr ça va dit
café je sais qu'on a une cafetière dans
camping car ça n'a pas marché
ah bon pourquoi pas
je crois qu'elle n'a pas voulu céder
mais bonjour les gars du café dangereux
vous auriez peut budget
[Musique]
ouais ouais je suis allé regarder les
étoiles il semble qu'elle était derrière
les rochers avec troy
j'ai
et
[Applaudissements]
les treuils quoi on est où là
hu magnifique
c'était incroyable hier soir non ouais
ok faut pour tourner là bas
quoi tu vas me laisser comme ça oui t'as
pas envie de recommencer
djè
et oh tu es là au coup fait qu'est ce
que tu faisais est désolé tu peux pas
témoigner comme ça ok j'ai flippé grave
ok ça va sur rai salut
c'est le bon taisez-vous ça y est on
croit rêver
alors sa magie des manants il se passe
rien du tout fichier j'aurais pas
allumer les phares hier pour à des trucs
sur des gros rochers là-bas ou un truc
dans le genre
arrête un peu de brasse de l'air c'est
tout ce que tu fais oui mais ma bien
fait ça pourquoi on a fait ça
quelle conne mais le dis à personne je
comptais pas le dire toi non plus dit
rien c'est quelque chose dieu fait chier
tu as vu oued
il a un joli hâle et l'arrachement
allons réfléchir autour d'une bière
d'accord j'ai soif et j'en ai marre moi
je n'aurais jamais dû venir le désert à
la con j'aurais dû rester chez moi mais
c'est pas possible
attends je vais réessayer j'y crois pas
ok la batterie est morte et on ne peut
plus rien y faire donc c'est mort génial
je suis désolé ce week end vient un
[ __ ] de cauchemar non ça fait rien on
va trouver une solution on va trouver
une solution est la solution c'est qu'on
va devoir faire le chemin inverse à pied
jusqu'à la route
c'est à seulement 16 kilomètres c'est
pas si terrible j'ai bien entendu 16 km
j'ai des talons dry bonne canyon on
dirait un coupe gorge
ok je vais aller réveiller rosemary
et un bout là dedans et b tu te
réveilles aux roses
jay jay o quoi robin qu'est ce qu'il ya
je crois qu'elle est morte
elle n'est pas morte elle dort c'est
tout pas vrai ce serait une overdose
est ce qu'elle est morte mardi fissures
pas
[ __ ] c'est pas possible
elle a pu faire une overdose
écoutez une nouvelle ça arrive
si on prend d'autres trucs avec sa part
inna je crois pas tu l'as fait où tu
l'as acheté reste quoi c'est toi qui l'a
fait et où tu l'as acheté je les ai
achetés mais je connais le gars attend
folle combiné avec quoi et s'était assis
je sais pas tout ce qu'on trouve dans la
rue pendant ce qu'est ce que tu deviens
connais ça suffit là c'est toi qui l'a
tuée
et toi ferme ta gueule
faut qu'on commence à marcher maintenant
on n'aura pas assez d'eau pour tenir
[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
c'est surréaliste [ __ ]
c'est parti
ce
[Musique]
on trouve du réseau doigt quelqu'un doit
appeler ses parents
zack semblait tombe
m
[Musique]
je crois qu'ils sont prêts à partir
et
on en a tous fini avec le camping car
non quand tu auras fini ton sac à dos
royal est d'accord
parfait
[Musique]
c'est pas loin ça troy on avait roulé
environ 12 kilomètres de ce côté donc il
nous faut quatre bonnes heures pour
revenir sur nos pas
on est où
sinon on sait où on va me souviens pas
est passée par là et j'ai fait attention
qu'ils n'étaient pas tous défoncés aussi
pavé la nuit commence à tomber
on n'a plus beaucoup de torts ouais je
sais bien mais si on continue par là bas
il se pourrait alors non regarde le
soleil on n'a pas beaucoup de temps il
faut qu'on continue je me souviens de
cette crainte est de cette montagne
j'ai déjà vu cette nouvelle on
réfléchisse à un plan elles se
ressemblent toutes
[ __ ] de montagne dans cette direction
on montera le camp plus tard d'isoler si
je panique perdu on en fait des airs de
merde ferme là et continuent d'avancer
et en temps ça suffit les conneries des
[ __ ] de route les côtes ça va aller
d'accord
tu as quelque chose non
rien du tout
ou est ce qu'on est
et j'en sais rien
merci
c'est tout ce qui nous reste en gros et
ouais
alors ça donne quoi rien du tout fait
chier j'étais censé la paix aujourd'hui
et une vie j'étais censé l'appeler pour
lui souhaiter une bonne chance pour
demain elle joue une pièce de
shakespeare en plus de ça comment elle
s'appelle olivia elle a 7 ans et elle
fait une magnifique hermia sa femme
secteur ex femme
merci
bon sinon
on serait dans un parc national c'est ça
il devrait y avoir des patrouilles de
rogers
le truc c'est c'est que quelqu'un ici a
dit à quelqu'un qu'il allait dans le
désert jeudi à jamie qu'on allait avec
asseoir
et un [ __ ] de génie en fait bravo
quelqu'un d'autre oui papa je vais au
milieu de nulle part avec un groupe de
hippies pour assister un festival de
merde
non non enserre la famille de rose marie
et quelques amis savent qu'on est là
mais je pense pas qu'ils attendent de
nouvelles ça fait deux jours qu'on est
là quelqu'un on a vu des rangers ce
parce que là on n'a toujours pas trouvé
la route je veux dire combien de
bouteilles d'eau et ce qui nous reste
c'est bien ce qui me préoccupe
tu crois vraiment que c'est une bonne
idée de bars être clair mon dîner partie
au feu fait tourner je crois que c'est
une grande idée
maxime vous allez être d hydrater j'ai
besoin de me retourner le crâne et
attendez j'ai un peu peur et je crois
qu'il ya un truc qui cloche dans ma
tente
tu pourrais venir avec moi il jeter un
coup d'oeil merci
alors qu'est ce qu'il ya dax quoi ça va
ouais mais là ça va super
qu'est ce que je fous là gagner mille
fois plus intelligent que moi
je suis qu'un pauvre con
ok ok ça va aller ça va non
[Musique]
oh la vache qu'est ce qui t'arrive
arquette chose ma mort du coup il faut
qu'on veut c'est bon je tenais venez
nous aider à les bouger vous qu'est ce
qui se passe et robin robin mais
qu'est-ce qu'il ya rien
il s'est fait mordre par un serpent a
dégoté aller tout un tas de bestioles
dans le genre perçoit sa dette
ouais tu as que tout le monde reste loin
des puissants ok [ __ ] c'est
rallye-raid on va devoir te poser un
garrot sur l'âge est ce que vous savez
ce que vous faites au moins mais portel
est ce qu'on va sucer devenant ou un
truc comme ça en fait ça sert à rien la
partie web
il faudra le recevoir de 40 minutes ok
vous savez quoi
vous emmenez ras le cul tout ça est en
train d'arriver parce que parce que on a
accepté de vous aider donc vous savez
quoi je me casse vous n'êtes qu'une
bande de minables et en plus vous porter
la poisse je me tire j'en ai rien à
[ __ ]
hassira fonds fresca que je perde
magellan si ce serpent était venimeux il
faut qu'on l'emmène à l'hôpital saint
louis va mourir ouais ouais mais le truc
c'est qu'on est pas qu il doit bien y
avoir une rousse d'une voiture où
quelque chose
ok attendu
saurai où l hôpital ok le soleil et la
céleste donc l'ouest est là et on vient
de la barre donc on doit aller à l'ouest
non ça me paraît sensé on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps et le seul truc que je
vois si ce [ __ ] désert ouais je suis
revenue je vous en prie alors c'est quoi
votre plan un bal plan c'est de
continuer de marcher c'est tout ce qu'on
peut faire pour l'instant continuer de
marcher on va pas continuer de marcher
qu'est ce que tu fais de wade on va
devoir le laisser là qua non est la
raison
si on le laisse là il faut que quelqu'un
reste avec lui d'accord d'accord dax
peut rester avec quelqu'un doit
retourner auprès de lui maintenant
allons-y
venez je vous ai dit de venir
on arrive je vais serrer d'accord il
faut que je leur sers il faut que je
servi en force pour te garder en forme
et pouvoir et là ça fait mal quand la
sht abandonnerai pas quoi on va devoir
marcher dans cette direction vous partez
il faut juste que tu fasses du feu
d'accord comment tu veux que je fasse en
fait comme ça si on se retrouve perdue
on sera capable de revenir ici et donc
vous allez revenir
ouais d'accord je vais faire un feu wade
revient au plus vite avec lesgourgues
alors attendons reste avec lui c'est
d'accord et fait pas de conneries
comment je vais faire ça va aller mon
pote
il est cool non il n'est pas cool c'est
un connard et on le sait tous les deux
ok il sauve sa peau si tout c'est
comment faire un feu ouais reste
concentré d'accord et je suis concentré
c'est juste ok j'ai confiance en toi et
faut que tu reviennes bien sûr que je
vais revenir non orange est laissée ici
réfléchi butin dès qu'on a trouvé
quelqu'un je m'assurerai qu'ils dégagent
tous d'ici et moi je reviendrai vous
chercher moi-même
ensuite on pourra aller boire une bière
tous les trois comme on l'avait prévu au
départ et on n'aura plus besoin de gérer
ces abrutis d'accord allait gagner
ouais c'est ce que je me disais bon à
toi tu ne va nulle part où je botte le
cul ok alors bougez pas dit si tu es
quand je reviendrai il y aura des
hamburgers des stripteaseuses et de la
picole et puis c'est quoi ça une toute
petite morsure
ça va aller t'inquiète je sais que tu
peux le faire
on se revoit très vite fait juste que tu
as à faire ok j'aurais bien singer ok je
vais faire un feu d'accord et ils vont
revenir avec des secours parce qu'elles
vont voir le feu ils vont nous sortir de
là et ta jambe va te faire mal un moment
et tu sais un jour on en rigolera enfin
ta soif
ok juste un peu parce que tu sais tout
ce que je touche finit toujours en
lambeaux tu vois
à
robin tu sais quoi les gars on marche
depuis jambes quatre ou cinq heures
maintenant j'ai pas envie de penser au
pire ne pense pas au pire tu sais quoi
faut vraiment que tu fermes ta gueule il
faut qu'on trouve un point en hauteur et
ravale ton sourire de débiles aussi ça y
est ok je me dépêche
maintenant faut que le feu partent oui
je sais je sais je sais je sais que j'ai
des flammes ça y est tu as vu j'ai
réussi le feu a pris ok ça valait
d'accord
ok ça va mieux le feu a pris tu vois les
flammes vont grandir ça va faire un gros
feu et ils pourront revenir
et c'est pas la bonne route
attendez c'est quoi ça [ __ ] regarder
ben je crois que c'est les dunes de
sable dax arrêtez pas d'en parler et
c'est un endroit touristique je crois
ici ici c'est un truc à touristes alors
il ya des gens disent des gens qui j'ai
fait et viseur allez allez allez allez
je sais tu peux le faire aller
et vont revenir
je veux pas te faire peur mais je crois
que je devrais te dire quelque chose je
crois que tu es mon meilleur ami wade tu
es tu es mon meilleur ami et je
t'apprécie non je t'aime
[Musique]
on
oh
[Musique]
alors rien mon téléphone sera bientôt
moi il ya forcément quelqu'un quelque
part c'est [ __ ] de dunes ya sûrement
des mecs qui viennent faire du buzz et
c'est exactement le genre d'endroit où
il irait on est d'accord fesci sont ces
[ __ ] de route où elle son bordel et a
pas de route chéri ya aucune [ __ ] de
route paraît pure l'école et jade a raté
pitié les gars on doit serrer les coudes
ouais c'est ça écoutez on aura bientôt
plus d'eau on va crever ici je peux plus
je peux plus avancer
robinson est encore un peu dans non non
non oublie ce que je viens de dire je
suis morte
ouais tu les noms sacrés foutrait
m'adresse plus la parole je te jure
devant dieu [ __ ] ce comment on a pu en
arriver là
on est ici depuis plusieurs jours on n'a
vu personne aucune antenne relais aucune
trace de pneu rien du tout [ __ ] c'est
quoi ce bordel on a fait au moins 80 km
écoutez on va devoir encore camper cette
nuit mais comment avec quoi j'en sais
rien j'en sais rien je vais aller voir
je vais aller voir et essayer de trouver
quelque chose
on reprendra la route demain matin
d'accord
fermez les yeux ouais t'as raison
[Musique]
pourquoi tu me fais ça
à
[Musique]
troyer toi vous m'avez fait faire ce
voyage je m'en fiche de tout les autres
tu sais
écoute il faut qu'on fasse quelque chose
dit quelque chose et
[Musique]
non je vais pas
ok d'accord c'est pas vraiment l'endroit
idéal pour me faire ça
[Musique]
non tu peux pas partir
je peux pas partir comme ça il m'a
abandonnée sur le bord de la route à
l'est de blé j'en ai marre c'est bon va
te faire [ __ ]
je vais tenter ma chance je vais tenter
ma chance au quai
[Musique]
en
on est bien perdue [ __ ]
[Musique]
merde
fichiers
c'est pas vrai
merde au
[Musique]
ils reviendront jamais
y reviendrons pas
[Musique]
mais bon
m
ma mère est morte pendant que tu étais
en prison je suis désolé
je le savais pas
comment tu aurais pu le savoir on sait
pas parler depuis l'époque où on avait
dix ans et on était des bonnes amies
avant si on s'en sort j'aimerais
j'aimerais vraiment corps deviennent des
amis
moi aussi
je peux te poser une question bien sûr
tu voulais vraiment 8 amer
ouais
pourquoi
elle était devenue folle
tu sais quand j'avais tout juste 15 ans
elle s'est acharné sur moi
robin était déjà parti mon père et moi
vous pouvez que la regarder son bris et
je crois pas qu'il existe pire que ça
ne plus être capable de contrôler son
esprit elle était parano et pensais que
mon père l'a trompée
il aurait pu se disputer toute la nuit
sans raison il ne l'aurait pas envoyer
balader
il avait une arme dans la chambre en cas
d'urgence elle est rentrée à la maison
un soir et elle n'arrêtait pas de lui
crier dessus à propos de à propos des
étudiantes et elle avait ce truc dans le
regard
elle lui a foncé dessus avec un couteau
et tu vois je l'aimé tellement nos pères
je lui ai tiré dessus
j'avais jamais tiré au pistolet avant ça
un chai
je suis vraiment vraiment désolé
et au rose marie aussi
on devrait dormir un peu et robin
il sait tout ça il sait rien du tout et
il saura jamais
où
[Musique]
beaucoup
une
vous
je
[Musique]
nous
on
non
[Musique]
écoute moi ça va pas de plaire mais je
dois marcher seul nom robyn écoute moi
j'ai beaucoup repensé à la position du
soleil qui ont roulé d'accord il était à
l'ouest je le sais je suis certain que
si je marche je t'en prie tu peux pas me
laisser avait que robin les filles ont
besoin de toi tu dois rester avec elle
elle n'y arriverons pas sans toi ces
fonds et couzier je peux pas te perdre
toi aussi
on n'a pas d'autre option si j'y vais
pas on va tous mourir ici
fais moi confiance dès ma petite soeur
et c'est ce que font les grands voyages
d'accord j'ai un bon sens de
l'orientation tu le sais bien
rappelle-toi au centre commercial
tu savais jamais où on avait garé la
voiture un ça va aller et je serais
revenu en a rien de temps tu me promets
pêche te le promets je vais revenir je
te le promets je t'aime tu en fais pas
je vais nous sortir de là c'est à mon
tour de te protéger
ça va aller
moi aussi j'étais
[Musique]
comment on est censé faire un feu alors
que ton frère en et le briquet un tu te
prends pour mac gyver maintenant eh ben
j'ai hâte de voir ça
août a appris à faire ça on allait
souvent campé quand on était petit ok il
nous reste un peu d'eau non tiens bois
robin sera bientôt là t'es sûr vraiment
tu lui as donné tout ce qui nous reste
de ta ta même pas pensé à partager ou a
demandé elle en a besoin
va te faire [ __ ] allez tous vous faire
[ __ ]
et tu sais quoi robin ne reviendra pas
il reviendra pas parce que il est mort
face contre terre dans un ancien terrain
de fos est mort et c'est comme ça qu'on
va tous finir on est déjà mort ouais je
sais pourquoi tu regardes pas les choses
en face
on est complètement foutue wave asie
continue va courir avec ta copine d'abba
elle a une botte de tampon allez donc
vous apitoyer sur votre sort
or fichiers [ __ ]
troy quoi je dois aller faire pipi quoi
bah va là bas
non non je veux pas aller là bas comme
si j'en avais quelque chose à [ __ ] je
vais nulle part moi alors des barres de
toit
[ __ ] de claque et je sais où j'en sais
rien moi y'a un rocher là bas il regarda
un autre là bas encore un autre là bas
il te reste plus qu'à choisir va loin
dit vraiment un connard j'arrive à peine
à marceau je suis désolé mon poussin
et ça va
et si robin ne revenait pas et va
revenir
tu sais comme tu es parti il a pris soin
j'aimerais tellement d'histoires à
raconter
il va revenir
moi confiance
bien fauconnier retardons
c'est pas vrai quoi
regarde c'est quoi ce truc
une tempête de sable pour qu'on bouge
elle est fière
merde
c'est quoi ce pas
eh les gars
[Musique]
et
télex toi c'est quoi ton problème
c'est quoi ce bordel
oui justin qu'est ce que j'en sais
elle est bien où il est
rave un peu plus loin à bande de
connards
bonsoir et nous apporter
[Musique]
ce que je suis en bas
sur les andes
allez pour pas partir s'un jasper hale
et dépêche toi
pourquoi y aller
pas où elle est d'accord
le faire les filles n'a pas s'en faire
pour f
on doit descendre le temps ordinaire
[Musique]
allez
jasper
[Musique]
nous
et
fait ça
petit
[Musique]
ça y est elle est passée
allez bien
tout le monde va bien ok on va retrouver
jasmin maintenant je crois qu'elle est
partie par là et trois vivant c'est
mieux que quatre morts tu crois pas et
je suis presque sûr qu'elle s'est
accroupi et quelque part comme nos sens
de l'argent que tu me saoules rabat avec
elle à rejoindre isère on va la
retrouver
merde
oh la vache
ça
[Musique]
robin est parti de ce côté à bien votre
ce côté-ci non non je ne vais pas suivre
dont crétins deux frangins je lui fais
confiance bien puisque toi super et du
goût d'aller aux 1re à bord j'adore
il reste là ouais t'as raison continue
de marcher c'est bien plus sûres regarde
là elle va finir comme elle vous allez
crever et moi c'est pour sortir
[Musique]
allez on va faire 10 r
alors depuis le plus haut sommet à les
affaires 10r relents et fort qu'il
s'envole cette espèce de saloperies
justin racines
[ __ ] de désert c'est vrai
[Rires]
ah oui tu peux le faire
une fois au fond du trou on peut que
remonter dicton de merde
gk rester dans la brèche allez ça
ressemble vachement un sentier membres
ah la vache à lait
[Musique]
il
on
où
en
[Musique]
non
les offres
à s'arrêter
[Musique]
bon
je suis avec vous
[Musique]
justin militaire
on
je suis crevé je suis d'isère à la con
souvenirs à venir du [ __ ] de dr ben
quoi y'a plus de respect tu vas tu joues
si tu aimerais tu vas tous les tuer
écoute moi bien non m'écoute pas
m'écoute pas
[Musique]
ap
m
napa
il
vaches
[Musique]
où
non
[Musique]
je
c'est tellement beau
c'est ce que tu viens
tél
peut-être
oh
[Musique]
non non
je te l'avais dit olivia je te l'avais
dit que je reviendrais
lâche moi toi
[Musique]
le
vous
[Musique]
[Musique]
m
on
oui
[Musique]
ça
et puis relevé
le
soucy l'efs m'ennuie au sein de la
gauche borelli
[Musique]
petit chocolat souvent
je voudrais car au fond d'eux
m
[Musique]
mouss goldwyn c'est tout le pack d'ist
commentent ils
une capture
oh
ni galop
emportée comme un standing à l'eau
oui
tam toa dessus
[Musique]
promotion
et le wat le culte soit on oublie venu
chez ma perruche et
hugo est cocasse
il aux mines est ce que c'est grave
[Musique]